E
TIMES YESTERDAY.
>> Jacqui: PRESIDENT BIDEN
STILL SEEMS TO THINK HE'LL BE ON
HIS SIDE AT THE END OF THE DAY.
ELECTION DAY IS TOMORROW AND THE
CALIFORNIA RECALL.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HEADING TO
CAMPAIGN WITH GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM LATER TODAY.
TOP G.O.P. CHALLENGER LARRY
ELDER CONTINUING HIS CAMPAIGN
AGAINST GOVERNOR BREVETS BRING
IN MARTHA McCALLUM, ANCHOR OF
"THE STORY."
STRAIGHT FROM LOS ANGELES.
SHE'S THERE FOR SPECIAL
COVERAGE.
HEY, MARTHA.
>> HEY, JACQUI.
>> Jacqui: THE PRESIDENT IS
TRYING TO SAVE NEWSOM SEAT.
WHAT YOU SEE IS THE BIGGEST
CAUSES OF THE RECALL?
HOW LIKELY IS IT THAT NEWSOM
HANGS ON GIVEN SOME OF THE
RECENT POLLING THAT SHOWS
REPUBLICANS ARE PRETTY MUCH
DIRECTLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
DEMOCRATS NOT SO MUCH.
DEEPLY BLUE STATE.
THIS HAS BEEN, IT WAS ONCE SEEN
AS A LONG SHOT COMING TO PASS.
>> IT'S SO FASCINATING.
AS YOU SAY, JACQUI, DEMOCRATS
OUTNUMBER REPUBLICANS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA 2-1.
NEVERTHELESS THERE WAS THIS
SHOCKING SORT OF GROUNDSWELL,
ABOUT 2 MILLION PEOPLE SIGNED
PETITIONS TO RECALL
GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
THAT ALL HAPPENED DURING THE
HEAT OF COVID, DURING HIS
EVENING OUT AT THE FRENCH
LAUNDRY.
PEOPLE STARTED TO GET TICKED OFF
FEELING THAT THERE WERE RULES
FOR THE BUT NOT FOR ME.
ENORMOUS NUMBERS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES, MANY OF THEM OWNED
BY MINORITY, BLACK LATINO, STORE
OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S AN INTERESTING LITMUS TEST
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE SEE IN
TURNOUT, WE SEE IN TERMS OF HOW
AGGRAVATED PEOPLE ARE WITH ALL
THAT.
IT'S AN UPHILL BATTLE.
THERE'S 46 REPUBLICAN OR 46
CANDIDATES RUNNING AGAINST GAVIN
NEWSOM, NOT ALL OF THEM
REPUBLICANS.
HE IS BRINGING IN THE BIG GUNS
COME PRESIDENT BIDEN COMING IN
FOR A SPEECH THIS AFTERNOON.
KAMALA HARRIS WAS HERE ON
FRIDAY.
26% BY THE MOST RECENT POLL.
ONE OF THE INTERESTING THINGS
FOR PEOPLE TO KEEP IN MIND IS
THAT GAVIN NEWSOM NEEDS TO CROSS
THE 50 PLUS VOTE THRESHOLD AND
TO HANG ON IN THE GOVERNOR'S
SEAT.
IF HE LOSES THAT GETS 49% OF THE
VOTE, SOMEONE ON THE OTHER SIDE,
LARRY ELDER OR CAITLYN JENNER,
THEY COULD WIN DEVOTE WITH JUST
20% WITHOUT PAROLE PLURALITY OF
THE REMAINING.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM
COVEN NEWSOM.
JUST DON'T KNOW.
LEAVE, WALK OUT AFTER HE PUT THE
BALLOT IN THE BALLOT BOX BECAUSE
HE DOESN'T WANT PEOPLE GOING TO
THE SECOND PART OF THE QUESTION
WHICH IS IF NOT GAVIN NEWSOM,
WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE
REPLACE HIM.
>> Jacqui: SO MUCH OF THIS IS
A REFERENDUM OF NEWSOM'S
HANDLING ON COVID.
LARRY ELDER'S OPPOSITION TO THAT
FUELING ENERGY AROUND THE
RECALL?
>> I THINK YOU NAILED IT.
GAVIN NEWSOM WANTS PEOPLE TO
FORGET ABOUT HIS HANDLING OF
COVID.
THE SITUATION HAS IMPROVED IN
TERMS OF CASES.
HE IS SAYING THIS IS A
REPUBLICAN RECALL.
HE IS SAYING THIS IS AN
ANTI-VAXX, ANTIABORTION.
THERE'S A GROWING NUMBER OF
INDEPENDENT VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
GROWING MOMENTUM IN LATINO
VOTERS.
YOU'VE SEEN LARRY ELDER SAYING
HE'S TRYING TO CONVINCE LATINO
VOTERS TO VOTE TO RECALL GAVIN
NEWSOM.
THOSE ARE INTERESTING AREAS TO
KEEP MY OWN, INDEPENDENT VOTERS,
LATINO VOTERS.
DO THEY SHOW, EVEN IF THEY DON'T
SUCCEED IN RECALLING NEWSOM,
WHAT ARE THEY SHOWING TERMS OF
MOMENTUM OVERALL?
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE REALLY FED
UP WITH THE DIRECTION OF THIS
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL STATE,
MUSIC HISTORY.
THEY HAVE GOT A HOMELESS PROBLEM
THROUGH THE ROOF.
CRIME IS INCREASING.
BUSINESSES ARE HAVING TROUBLE
FUNCTIONING GIVEN THE STRUCTURE
AND LACK OF ENTICEMENTS TO BEGIN
AN OPEN AND GROW COMPANIES HERE.
>> Jacqui: GOING OUT TO A
BIRD'S-EYE VIEW, WHAT'S AT
STAKE.
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS SAID IT'S
ABOUT SENDING A MESSAGE THAT
DEMOCRATS WHO KEEP CONTROL OF
BOTH CHAMBERS HAD OF THE
MIDTERM, SHE'S CLAIMED THAT THE
RESULTS WOULD REVERBERATE DOWN
AND IMPACT REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
AND IMMIGRATION.
ANYONE WHO REPLACES NEWSOM HAVE
TO CONTEND WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
SUPER MAJORITY STATE LEGISLATOR.
COULD IT SEND A MESSAGE?
>> I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU SEE
SUCH BIG FIREPOWER COMING OUT
HERE TO BACK GAVIN NEWSOM.
PRESIDENT, VICE PRESIDENT,
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA PUT IN A
VIDEO MESSAGE.
I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
CONCERN.
I THINK THEY ARE A LITTLE BIT
WORRIED AS THEY LOOK TOWARDS THE
MIDTERM.
THIS ENORMOUS BILL MOVED INTO
THE HOUSE.
$3.5 TRILLION.
TAXATION IS BEEN THROUGH THE
ROOF.
YOU SEE A LOT OF BUSINESSES
MOVING TO PLACES LIKE AUSTIN AND
NASHVILLE, LEAVING CALIFORNIA.
THEY'VE HAD A DECLINE IN THEIR
POPULATION HERE FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN THE STATE'S HISTORY.
THIS IS WHERE PEOPLE WANTED TO
COME, THERE WAS INDEPENDENCE AND
FREEDOM TO START YOUR OWN LIFE,
START YOUR BUSINESS.
HAVE THE WESTERN FUTURE AND
OUTLOOK.
THAT'S CHANGED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE SPIRIT HAS REALLY ALTERED
OVER THE LAST 25 YEARS.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
INTERESTING TO SEE THE
UNDERLYING DYNAMICS OF THE VOTE
AS IT STARTS GETTING COUNTED
TOMORROW AND HOW MUCH TURNOUT IS
TOMORROW.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE WAITING TO
PUT BALLOTS IN THE BOX?
WE ARE PUTTING UP CLOSE EYE ON
IT.